Whoever plays Jennifer Walters, a.k.a.
She-Hulk, needs to have a commanding presence
in the courtroom as well as in fight scenes,
and she also needs stellar comedic timing.
Here are a few actors who would look great
in green for Marvel's Disney+ She-Hulk show.
Gina Carano has had a long career in action
roles film fans probably knew Carano either
as the merciless henchwoman Angel Dust in
the first Deadpool movie or as one of Hobbs'
secret agents in Fast & Furious 6.
What makes Carano stand out as a potential
She-Hulk is her real-world experience in martial
arts.
She started out competing in Muay Thai before
deciding to become an MMA fighter, winning
all but one of her bouts.
Her martial arts background and muscular physique
would be great for She-Hulk's superhero battles,
and her bravado will work well during the
dialogue-heavy scenes.
"What the hell happened?"
"We met Dom's girlfriend.
She's lovely."
Recently, Carano has gained a whole new fanbase
thanks to her role as the mercenary Cara Dune
in The Mandalorian which also, as luck would
have it, airs on Disney+.
Bringing her in to finally play a superhero
just makes sense.
Lena Headey spent eight years playing Cersei
Lannister, one of the most compelling antagonists
in all of television.
Headey is only 5'5" in real life, but you
could never tell on Game of Thrones.
The actor is just that good at commanding
the room.
Wouldn't it be great to see her bring that
commanding energy to a super-strong, super-green
lawyer?
As Cersei, she managed to balance her character's
truly human struggles with her ruthless climb
to power.
The challenge of balancing Lawyer Jennifer
and Superhero Jennifer is tricky, but Headey
can definitely pull it off.
It certainly doesn't hurt that she has previous
experience with action scenes in Terminator:
The Sarah Connor Chronicles and the Purge
series.
Plus, it would be delightful to see Cersei
stare down the biggest bads of the Marvel
Universe.
D'Arcy Carden is having a moment.
In addition to playing Janet, the helpful
celestial assistant on The Good Place, audiences
have also recently seen her on HBO's critically
acclaimed Bill Hader-led hit Barry.
While cheery, personality-less Janet was very
funny in the first season, the rest of the
series shows how she slowly evolves into a
more complex and opinionated being.
Carden's versatility shines in every version
of Janet she portrays.
"It turns out that the best Janet was the
Janet that was inside Janet all along."
She has a knack for bringing genuinely sincere
moments into her comedic roles, and not all
actors can pull that off.
A She-Hulk show would need that nuance to
avoid getting too serious or too silly.
On top of her comedy background, Carden did
a little stunt work for The Good Place and
has said how much she loved it.
As that series wraps up, this is the perfect
time to cast her in something more action-packed...
and a green super-powered lawyer sounds just
about right.
Outside of television, Adrianne Palicki might
be best remembered as the cold, conniving
assassin Ms. Perkins in John Wick, but her
career is full of action roles, big and small.
Her work in the sci-fi/comedy series The Orville
mixes action, humor, and science fiction.
And with her 5'11" stature, Palicki seems
like a natural fit for She-Hulk.
Palicki has already been a Marvel hero as
fan favorite Bobbi Morse on Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
But there is a precedent for actors to play
different superheroes, even in the same comic
universe.
Brandon Routh joined the Arrowverse as the
Atom after his lead role in Superman Returns,
while Chris Evans and Michael B. Jordan, two
different Johnny Storm actors, both went on
to even bigger roles within the MCU.
Who says Palicki can't be brought in to play
a different superhero?
Kathryn Hahn's body of work runs the gamut.
There's maniacal Olivia Octavius, a new take
on the classic Spider-Man villain Doc Ock,
in Into the Spider-Verse.
Then there's the kind Rabbi Raquel Fein [FINE]
in the TV show Transparent.
And recently she took on the title role on
HBO's Mrs. Fletcher, which explores the vulnerability
of being on your own after your kids leave
for college.
"Oh.
Breathe."
"Okay, but I think maybe you should listen
to the candle."
"Mm.
I breathe."
The role proves Hahn can embody the hardworking
side of Jennifer Walters, who genuinely cares
about justice and defending her clients.
However, a role that stands out above the
others for this fan-casting is the acerbic,
driven political consultant Jennifer Barkley
on Parks and Rec. Barkley was only on the
show periodically, but every appearance was
a treat.
Hahn portrayed Barkley as completely confident
and frank to a fault, and she can pull so
much from that scene-stealing role into the
sharp-tongued, career-driven Walters.
Fans have suggested that Aisha Tyler portray
Jennifer Walters for years.
At 6'0", Tyler is certainly already the height
to play She-Hulk.
Voicing secret agent Lana Kane on the adult
animated series Archer, Tyler has also proven
she can play a career-driven woman who also
happens to fight bad guys and blow things
up.
Tyler has been part of several talk show casts
and knows how to handle a room on her own,
much like Jennifer herself would.
While her film and TV work is extensive, she
hasn't had a chance to lead her own show,
and this feels like the right fit.
It doesn't hurt that Tyler is a self-professed
nerd, either.
Imagine how hyped she'd be playing a superhero.
In many ways, Laura Prepon's acting career
has always been tied to how tall she is.
In her breakout role as Donna on That '70s
Show, one of the main running jokes was about
Donna towering over her boyfriend.
It seems fitting for 5'10" Prepon to use that
height to her advantage in a role like She-Hulk,
where it wouldn't be treated like a joke.
On top of that, her smoky, droll voice is
perfect for the dialogue on a show like She-Hulk.
"Nothing wrong with that."
Prepon exhibits a cool confidence in her various
roles, and seeing her walk into a law office
with all the swagger of a super strong, beautiful,
brilliant lawyer would really work for this
character.
Since her time as felon Alex on Orange Is
the New Black is done, it would be fitting
for Prepon to jump to the other side of the
legal system.
Like her co-star Lena Headey, Gwendoline Christie
is at an interesting point in her career.
Her breakout role as Brienne of Tarth on Game
of Thrones won the hearts of millions of viewers,
and yet her short time as Phasma in the new
Star Wars trilogy felt like wasted potential.
Now that Game of Thrones is over, it's about
time she takes her experience with fight choreography
and jumps into another popular genre.
Christie is a funny, charismatic person in
real life, but she hasn't gotten to explore
that in her past roles.
Jennifer Walters would suit her strengths
to a T. And at 6'3", she's also the most physically
well-suited to play the character.
It's easy to imagine what a blast Christie
would have in a big, funny role like this
and she would totally rock a pantsuit.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.